I actually have a Bachelor of Science in
biology and came to set decoration and
very circuitous route after college I
went into research I always thought I
was going to be in the medical field I
worked in hospitals and ambulances and
all kinds of things all through college
and when I went into research I
absolutely abhorred it I being low woman
on the totem pole I had to do a lot of
the shall we say mutilation of animals
in order to harvest the materials that
we needed and I after a couple of years
I just couldn't do it anymore I couldn't
sacrifice one species for the good of
the human species I was not cut out for
it so in despair I called my brother who
had just graduated from film school at
NYU and I said what am I going to do
with my life he said well try film you
always written you're a good editor um
why don't you try that and I said okay
great sure what can I do how do I do
that and he said call some people I was
living in Cincinnati at the time and I
did I called some people and someone
eventually said we need an editing
intern and I said great I packed the car
moved to New York over the weekend found
an apartment with friend of mine and
started from there and eventually fell
into an art department job when someone
called me and said would you like to be
an art department PA and I said
certainly what's an art department and
what's a PA and I showed up for work and
was just eager and willing and and
thought it was the most fun I ever had
in my life and ended up driving the
decorator around and I learned at her
feet basically watching what she did
watching what she chose trying to learn
on my own reading books and figuring it
out
was in New York in that in the late 70s
early 80s and I just had a ball I loved
it it was the world's biggest scavenger
hunt and somebody paid me to do it I
thought okay I'm hooked people often
think that we're interior decorators
which we are to a certain extent that's
a small segment of of what we do but i
don't think mark Hampton ever had to do
a circus or you know some back lot in
you know some farm and ranch and
racetrack or some horror movie you never
know what we're going to be asked to do
to service the script so we're we're
sort of a combination of psychologists
and logistics expert and interior
decorator and manager of people were
human resources manager we bring so many
different talents to the one job
classification it's not it's hard to
describe to someone who hasn't done it
it's changing now because technology is
changing so much i mean i can remember
running around New York with a beeper in
my pocket and getting 911 beeps and
trying to find a payphone now of course
everyone's got a cell phone glued to
their ears or an iPad or you know you've
got your computer in your pocket and
you're constantly in touch with everyone
that the communication is very very very
quick the largest thing that's impacting
us right now is the role of computer
graphics in our industry and it's a
constantly evolving question of how do
we meld it into the existing
framework of the structure of our jobs
and the way they have have been for the
time that I've been in the industry
where do you use that technology and who
makes the decisions about where it gets
used and how how each department is
going to be woven into that fabric it's
it's a constantly evolving question
right now each each each job is
different
you